và giá tăng khả năng, lắp trả từ phía Iran và các lực lực lệ quan.
Ngay trong sáng nay thì Iran đã tiến hành hành hòa vụ tấn tốc tên nữa,
chả nữ ở Vào Israel, chúng tôi đã kết nối với phòng viên phòng wine,
thường chú đánh Việt Nam tại của bực chung đông.
Anh phòng wine, tình hình tại chung đông, nống lĩnh mức lộ như thế nào.
Bân, tổng thống đúng đúng nó trong đúng đúng đúng.
Mày mai nè mọng bây hai, một trong những mấy mây hàng đầu của của nội Mỹ đã được xử lúc trong cuộc thông thích
vào các cư sở hành nhân của Iran.
Mày mai đã thả sấu của bọn phá bọn kê mối của anh nặng mối lắm tấn.
Nể tấn công cư sở hành nhân phòng.
Trong khi các tổng gầm mi đã phòng bà mối tình lợt tù mà hốc vào các cư sở hành nhân
na thàn và Ispa Hanh.
Ngay sau cuộc tấn công theo chuyên thông nhả nước Iran,
cứ quan năng lượng wind từ Iran đã linan các cuộc không biết của Mỹ,
nhằm vào bà cư sở hành nhân cho yếu của nước này.
Đông thời khẳng định sẽ không bao giờ tư bò chung trình hành nhân.
Chứ như dưng diên miến theo thàn căn thẳng,
như nước ở khu vực Trung đông đã liên tiến kêu gọi các bên liên quan kìm chế,
chẳng theo thàn xuống độc.
Trong đỏ vụ trường ngoại sao ở lập xíu quốc,
kêu gọi cộng đông cúp tế tăng cường nấu lực trong mối cảnh vô cùng nhảy cảnh thiện này.
Nhằm đắt được một dài pháp chính trị,
đảm bảo chấm rất quốc quốc khung hoàn và mở ra 1 trang mới,
để đặt được ăn ninh và 1 định trong khu vực.
Nó cả mọi nè.
Chứ tình khiến thẳng léo thàn nguy hiểm,
cậu đường Quốc tế đang lo ngại mua cơ xung độc lăng dọng tại Trung đông.
Những nước đạn nông loạt kêu gọi thân quyền liên quan kìm chế,
còn đối loại đối thoại.
Trong bài đăng trên nạn sáo hội X,
tổng thức kiến thế thủ Quốc,
ăn tôn nhiều một tế đez,
mấy tổ lông ngại trước cuộc tấn công quân sự của Mỹ vào Iran.
Nạn định đe là sửa theo tháng huy hiểm tại khu vực Trung đông,
và là mỗi đe choa chức tiếp đối với hợp mình và ăn định Quốc tế.
Tối kêu hỏi các quốc gia thành viên giảm léo thàn căn thằng,
và tôn thủ cân như vụ của mình theo dễn trường liệu quốc.
Cũng như các quy tác của lịch pháp Quốc tế,
trong thời các ngủ yểm này,
biểu tối quân trọng là phải chắc mọi vòng sợi hỗ loạt.
Cũng của tại pháp quân sự nào,
có đường dung dung nhất phía trước là ngoài rau,
trong Iran của tổng thống tròm cũng vó phản những ý kiến trái chiều.
Chua tịch hả viện Mỹ Mike Johnson,
lãnh gạo phê đa số tại thường viện thuộc đàn cộng hoa choo thân,
và một số vị sĩ đảng dân chủ của hỗ ông tròm.
Trong khi một số hàng vị sĩ thuộc đảng dân chủ và cộng hoa,
choo rằng hình đậu của tổng thống là vượt quân,
khi không thông qua Quốc hội,
và có quyết cơ để nếu Mỹ vào một cuộc chính trành quy mô lớn.
Hạn ra sẽ ra cuộc xuống lộn,
đo vượt xong vào vi khu vực trường lộn.
Hãy rửa lãnh đến nhé,
và nè choo cái rất là quan trọng này.
Hãy rửa con sát trên thế giới tí,
nếu hãy sẽ đo tí cơ,
hãy xong ở trường lộn này mới là cái lướn nhất thế giới,
và từ đó là cái kinh tế thế giới.
Nếu sẽ nghĩ tảy hợp gió bị tăng đợp gió rời,
sẽ tăng lên thế giới là cóm với cái cộng hoa của xong lộn gà quen nè là
thì cái kinh tế giới có thể lướng vào một cuộc xuống lửa.
Công tốt tế đã lên tiếng kiêu gọi khách bên thình chỉ tránh liều thang cân thằng.
Các cuộc già như Trung Quốc, Việt bản, thành Quốc,
ai ngủ xe lia, y dilih lần, đều nhất chỉ rằng đối thoại và giải phó ngoại giao,
là lựa giải duy nhất cho cuộc xuống lộn gẹn này tại Trung Đông.
Chá một tính bố đương ra và ngăn này,
bố ngoại giao iroan tệng mào iroan có quyền mào về ăn,
nên cuộc già và Trung quyền của mình mạnh phó lực.
Iroan cũng để ngọt hả năng giút khỏi hiệp lất không phụ biến phụ hiàn nhan.
Cây ông tổng giống lấp, cơ quan năng lượng,
quyền từ cuộc tế ra, phản, rộng,
trước khi khi khi khi khi khi khi khi này,
iroan thì các quan này sẽ chữ tập một cuộc học hình cấp của hội đồng thống lốc,
bảo vệ vòng vám nhằm rất thành viên trong ngày mai.
Mình trong lúc này thì giới đầu tư đăng cân nhắc một loạt kích và thị trường.
Khách nhau khi mà Mỹ,
căn giữ sau hơn vào cuộc xuống lộ Trung đồng và có khả năng sẽ sẽ ra các khi ủng lăng toàn,
nếu giả năng lợt tăng vào.